hi and welcome to my JavaScript tutorial
in which I will teach you how to code in
JavaScript by building your very own
basic game of Tetris I always find that
learning is easy by doing so if you're
the same this tutorial is definitely for
you and here you'll have a pretty neat
JavaScript game by the end of it this
tutorial is for super beginners and we
will be going through the fundamentals
of JavaScript as well as some import
functions that are gonna help us build
our Tetris game if you have never touch
code before this is a pretty good place
to start we will be going through some
CSS and HTML as well but just the basics
as you know this is a JavaScript
tutorial if you do have some prior
knowledge of HTML and CSS please do not
skip the first few lessons we need them
in order to set up our game feel free to
watch them on double-speed if you prefer
tetris is a simple grid based game in
which you as a user had to navigate 5
shapes or tetriminos down to the bottom
of your bridge the aim of the game is to
get the highest score by filling up rows
when your grid in order for them to
disappear and for you to gain points you
as the user can rotate your shapes and
you also have insider knowledge by
knowing which shape is coming up next
thanks to a grid to the side of your
grid in this game we are not gonna have
levels we are simply going to do a basic
version of the game basic functionality
and basic styling this is so you can
take it and make it fully your own I
would love to see all your finished
projects how you have made them your own
in terms of styling or leveling up so
please do share them with me please do
get in touch if you get stuck at any
point in this tutorial I am always more
than happy to help again please do use
my social links below so yeah let's get
going
in this walkthrough I'm gonna show you
my preferred code editor as well as the
bonus of how to set it up so that it
works for you like a sort of spell
checker if you will it will check your
code for mistakes and prompt you to
change things in order for it to work I
am also going to show you what a command
tour is and how to use it to access
files and folders on your computer as
well as speak to them and download
things from it okay so let's get going
first off start by downloading a code
editor I'm going to use
Atem if you go to item to i/o and
download the program that will be the
tool you use to write code in your
project
now copy it into your Applications
folder and add it to your dog
once there has been downloaded you will
use the command line system to create a
folder to store your project if you have
a Mac simply search for terminal in your
Launchpad if you're on a PC you need to
search for your command prompt tool now
open up your terminal and using LS you
can list all the directories now using
CD to enter a directory we navigate to
the desktop it is on the desktop that
we're going to create our project called
basic Tetris so using a command called
mukhtar we're going to make a directory
called basic Tetris okay great we now
have a folder to store all our code
files in it to go into this folder again
we use CD let's use the command CD to go
into this project if you ever want to
get out of this project we use CD with
two dots like this but we don't so let's
go back into it once in this folder we
need to create files go in it we do so
using a command called touch-touch we'll
create files we need to create an HTML
file CSS file for our styling and a
javascript file to hold our JavaScript
I'm going to choose to call them
index.html style.css and app.js okay
perfect
now using assam dot as we are using the
assam code editor we will prompt the
project to open in our item code editor
and there we go we are now set up to
start writing some code now i'm going to
show you some useful settings on item
that will make your life a whole lot
simpler
Atem allows us to add packages there are
literary loads and loads of packages out
there that you can pick and choose so
I'm simply gonna go through ones that I
find useful for my projects open Atem
and click on the item menu then install
shell commands
click on the drop-down and preferences
in preferences in the editor panel make
the following changes show in that guide
check shirt Invisibles check and tab
type soft now let's go over to our
terminal and type the following code
what we are essentially doing here is
downloading packages for Assam to use
via the command line tool
you
once these are all downloaded let's quit
awesome
now let's reopen it to see the packages
that we installed and go through the
more a little bit more one by one in the
navigation find packages and click on
the drop down you will see here all the
packages we installed use the command
line and APM command
we have Auto indent Auto a dent will
Auto and Daniel code correctly in your
files this is good for code readability
and considered best practice
you
awesome tangey ass is a package that
adds support for es five-year six-year 7
es 8 nodejs and more this means that it
will let us use features of all of them
in your code editor for example an arrow
function which you will definitely come
across is something that is a feature of
JavaScript ES 6 and above we are also
going to have something that will spell
check our code and check our JavaScript
code in a way that will notify us if
something isn't working correctly for
this we will use Linda J as standard
you
okay great you are now all set up to
start writing JavaScript projects let's
carry on
hi and welcome back in this project
we're gonna be using an HTML file and a
JavaScript file in order to make our
project hTML is a hypertext markup
language used as the basis of a web page
HTML consists of tags surrounded in
angular brackets like this the HTML tag
can be used to define headings titles
images links buttons there's a whole
load of tags available to your disposal
in this lesson we're gonna be focusing
on the HTML file and how to link it to
our other files such as our JavaScript
file and CSS stylesheet the first thing
we're going to do is make sure to check
our files are named accordingly the most
important thing is the ending or file
extension we need to make sure that we
use jeaious to let our code editor know
that we are going to be writing
JavaScript code in this file and to
treat it like a JavaScript file we also
need to do this for the stylesheet or
CSS file CSS stands for cascading style
sheet we will cover that in the next
lesson now we need to link the
javascript file to the HTML file we will
do so by putting a script tag in between
the head tag then using a Dom event
listener in our JavaScript to make sure
this tag is read
after all the code in this HTML file has
been that an alternative way to do this
is by putting the script tag at the end
of the document in the footer but this
is the way we're doing it for the sake
of the tutorial it is important to note
that in this script tag the source or
SRC as you can see here the text in
between the quotation marks needs to be
the relative path of where the
JavaScript file is as the file is in the
root of our folder we simply write up J
s if your app JS file happens to be in a
folder you will need to change this
relative path in the script tag
so to recap if the file is in the same
location as your HTML file we write this
and if it's in a subfolder to your
index.html file we write this replacing
the green folder with whatever you
you have named your folder please do
remember to keep your index.html file at
the root of your folder if you do not
our browser will not be able to read
this project well not without loads of
configuration anyway I am actually going
to flip over to our javascript file and
add the Dom event listener now too you
must make sure all our JavaScript in the
future is written in between these two
parentheses we need to make sure this is
done so that it's picked up by the
script tag you wrote earlier in our HTML
file okay so let's go ahead and add that
event listener to our javascript file
like so again the Dom content loaded
event fires when the initial HTML
document has been completely loaded and
passed this is without waiting for the
starchie's images and subframes to
finish loading the target of our event
is the document referring to the HTML
document okay now back to our HTML file
so now we're gonna link our stylesheet
in a very similar way but using a link
tag instead add the following tag in
between your head tag again make sure
the relative path of the file is correct
we do not need to add anything into our
CSS file for this to be picked up now
that we have licked our to other files
in our HTML file let's start by adding
some code to our body now we first need
to plan exactly what we want our Tetris
game to look like in terms of shape as
we're gonna be making a grid based game
I would suggest drawing this out fast or
using something like Google sheets like
me to get an idea of what we have to get
on with and tackle I'm gonna flip over
to Google sheets now I have actually pre
drawn this to give you an idea of what
to be aiming for you can make your own
grid as big or as little as you want
it's up to you so you can see here I
want to make my grid 20 squares tall and
ten squares and height so how would we
make these 200 squares we need to make
them in our HTML file and then add
styling to them with our style sheet or
CSS file so let's do it
let's code up to 200 divs in our HTML
file there are other ways of doing this
from the JavaScript filed that involve
creating an element 200 times using a
for loop but as we're just starting out
I think it's important to focus on a
more visual way of learning so we can
see what's happening now let's put these
200 divs and a div of its own that we
are gonna give a class name of grid to
we are doing this so we can contain the
200 is in a div of its own that we're
gonna start an our CSS later
now we are gonna want to display the
score let's do that an h3 tag like this
with a span inside of it like this h1 h2
h3 tags are all header tags h1 being
your main one and going down in size all
the way do you hit h8 okay moving on
let's give this fan an ID of score so we
know exactly which span tag to display
the future score in just in case we used
another span tag in our project as a
person class names IDs are unique and
can only be used once I am also going to
hard-code
a 0 here for now finally I'm going to
add a button using the button tag as I
want this button to start the game I'm
gonna give it a very clear ID or start
button ok let's save these files we are
going to right click just here so we can
open this file in our browser amazing
there you won't see the two hundred
tubes as they have no styling applied
yet you can see them if you inspect the
page if you do not know how to inspect
the page you can simply do so by
pressing down the ctrl button on your
keyboard and left clicking the browser
like this check out the sniff C
animation I did here it's also where you
view the console.log we will be using
the console log later it's a tool that
allows it to see what's going on under
the hood when writing JavaScript and is
super useful ok great thanks this lesson
let's move on after just a few questions
in this lesson we're going to be
covering CSS or cascading style sheets
CSS is a simple mechanism that allows
you to add styles so fonts add colors to
your web documents becoming a pro at
this takes a lot of practice we are
simply going to be doing the basics in
order for us to carry on learning
JavaScript as this is a JavaScript
tutorial
this will include styling to make our
grid look like a grid add colors to ah
tetriminos and touching a little bit on
flexbox once you have finished this
tutorial please do go back and add as
much styling as you want feel free to
share it with me I would love to see
your finished games okay let's start off
by giving some styling to our grid the
first thing we do is navigate to our
style.css file now let's pick up the div
with a class name of grid we tell our
stylesheet we are looking for a class by
using this dot before the class name so
as a recap we are picking out the div
with a class name of grid that has 200
divs inside of it let's say we want our
squares to be 20 by 20 pixels at a 10 by
20 grid that would mean we need to make
the width of our grid 200 pixels and the
height 400 pixels I'm gonna make it
yellow so we can see it in our browser
now we are also gonna style the divs in
the grid we do serve like this we put
the div element after the element with a
class name of grid by doing this we are
saying that we want to solve only the
divs in that element like this so
essentially all other divs we use in the
future in our project will be unaffected
by this styling okay so inside the
parenthesis we're gonna assign the
height and the width let's also make
them red just so we can see them in our
browser
okay let's save that file and refresh
our browser you will see the red squares
show up as a stuck over each other this
is the case by default divs do this they
stack of each other unlike h3
which appear in line this is where
flexbox comes in
we need to use flexbox to make sure the
red squares appear stacks and a line and
then stuck over each other as soon as
they don't fit in the grid div width
parameter let's add display flux and
save and refresh the browser and now we
have it we now have a grid we can work
with and start adding some JavaScript
code and game functionality to let's
move on just after a few questions
you
in this video I want to take a break
just explain what variables are and how
we use them in JavaScript so in
JavaScript you can store values in
something called variables they are
legal identifiers quite simply is this
so the variable X here equals one it is
important to note that when you declare
a variable its name must be unique you
can assign numeric value to a variable
like the number one or a string value
such as 1 and quick marks an array such
as 1 & 2 in an array a boolean such as
true or false or you can just leave it
undefined for later use like this now by
definition variables mean anything that
can vary so let's see this in action
let's get X and assign it to the value
23 note we do not use var again as we
have defined X above let's go ahead &
console.log that and you will see X has
now changed value now let's talk about
scope when defining variables it is
important to know that they have scope
variables have two types of scope global
scope will function scope meaning they
can only be accessed inside our function
let's have a look at this in action
here is a function I have written to
alert me with their name
you
let's put the var name here outside the
function
okay that works this is because it's a
globally scoped variable now I'm going
to move it here inside the function
this also worked as the variable is
declared and
side the function however what happens
if I now want to show you la outside of
this function
it will not work as the variable is not
being picked up as it's inside this
functioned scope essentially it's out of
our reach now okay got it now let's talk
a little bit more about constant depth
and how they differ from bar so when es6
came in it introduced two new ways to
create variables let and constants let's
look a little bit about the difference
between left and var fast let allows you
to declare variables that are limited to
a scope of a block statement unlike a
bar what does this mean well let's have
a look at an example okay so I'm going
to declare variable X here as one now
I'm gonna write a function here called
find X inside I'm gonna declare variable
X again as two now if I want an alert
telling me what to is inside this
function I will get two however what
will I get if I want to move the allow
outside of this function
I will get to as variable is global and
we declared it after the first
declaration now let's do the same but
using let so all I'm doing is writing
the same thing but replacing bar with
let
you
you will now see that we are getting one
as the other let inside the find X
function is out of our scope
now finally Const Const works in the
same way let does in that you cannot
access it if it is inside a function
however it is also constant as conferred
allude to once you have defined it you
cannot change it later on this is pretty
useful when working with big projects
and declaring what you do not want to be
changed let's have a look at this in our
code editor
you
okay so that we have it let's recap bar
a function scoped or globally scoped
variable let a block scoped variable and
Const a block scoped variable that
cannot be reassigned okay now we have a
grasp on variables let's go back to our
game of Tetris
in this lesson we're gonna start adding
functionality to our project by adding
some JavaScript code we will especially
be focusing on JavaScript arrays and how
we will be using them in order to make
our game an array is a special variable
which can hold more than one value at
one time if you have a list of items so
a list of Tomino names for example
storing the tetriminos a single
constants we'll do it like this however
what if you want to loop through these
tetriminos and find a specific one and
what if you had not 5 but 200 of them
the solution is an array an array can
hold many values under a single name and
you can access the value by referring to
an index number you will be using the
index number a lot in this course
JavaScript arrays are zero indexed
meaning that the first element of the
array is at index zero and the last
element is at the index equal to the
value of the arrays length property
minus one this is important for our game
but also for JavaScript array knowledge
in general the first thing we're going
to do is tell our JavaScript the width
of a grid in squares using Const so
let's flip over to our javascript file
now as the value will not change we are
going to use a Const so as a reminder
the Const keyword denotes a non mutable
view of mutable data
next we are gonna use something called a
query selector to look through our HTML
document and find the element with a
class name of grid document query
selector is an inbuilt JavaScript method
you will see here we are using dot again
as we are looking for a class name once
we find it sign it to the constant we
have decided to call grid now our
JavaScript knows that every time we type
grid and do something to grid we want it
to affect the element with a class name
of grid in our HTML 5 now we also want
our JavaScript to talk to all the
squares in our grid using the query
selector again but this time using
document query selects at all as we want
to collect all the divs inside the
element
the class name of grid we do this now
what we are going to do involves an
inbuilt JavaScript method called array
from you're going to use it to in layman
terms collect all the divs on our grid
or 200 of them and turn them into an
array we can work with now each div will
have a specific index number let's pass
these collector divs through array from
to make them an array and assign it to
let squares let's get our console up
here so we can see what our console log
tells us now hit refresh on your browser
okay great you will now see that these
squares is an array of 200 divs with
index numbers from 0 to 199 the reason
it says 0 to 1 9 9 instead of 1 to 200
is that the index count always starts at
0 what does this mean for us in our game
well we just need to learn how to count
a little differently let's have a look
at our grid and these squares inside
numbered by their indexes this is
something I made in Google sheets
earlier to make it easier for us
understand you will see that if we want
to be in the fifth square so this would
be the fifth square here we would need
to tell our JavaScript we want to be in
the index four of our squares array why
is this an array again because we
collected all the divs and pass them
through array from okay let's move on
the last thing I'm going to do for this
section is get a few more things from
our HTML document
we are using a hash here to indicate we
are looking for an ID so if you look on
HTML page as a reminder we gave this
span tag an idea of school and this
button an ID of start button let's go
ahead and pick them out again with our
query selector there is also a get
element by ID feel free to use that as
well I'm gonna use this query selector
okay great
that's it for this lesson let's recap
with just a few questions
you
in this video we're gonna take a quick
break to go over exactly what a function
is and why we use them functions are one
of the main building blocks of
JavaScript and in fact most languages in
JavaScript a function allows you to
write a block of code define it with a
name and execute it as many times as you
like it's all about recycling code with
functions in this video I will be
showing you how to write a super basic
function that we will later be adapting
to use in our own game of Tetris
okay so let's leap over to our code
editor so that I can show you a super
basic example of a function first so the
simplest example I'm gonna show you is a
function that sets off an alert the last
thing we're gonna do is write function
like this followed by a word I've chosen
to call my function this word should
really convey what is happening in my
function we do this make our code more
readable for colleagues simply if we're
forgetful I'm gonna choose to call my
function show a lot I am using camel
case for this camel case is the practice
of writing more than one word joined as
one but visually separated by making
each word after the first start with a
capital letter
it has no spaces or punctuation I
consider this the best practice for
writing functions okay so after naming
our function we write these two buckets
these two brackets are passing down
parameters into our function as we don't
have any just yet I will leave this lunk
now we have to put our block of code
that defines a function in a parenthesis
I'm going to make my function shown
alert like this you will see I'm writing
the inbuilt method of alert and passing
through is string a string is defined as
a word in these clip marks okay great
now let's test out what we have written
we can invoke a function like this
amazing so that's the basics now let's
pass parameter or two into our function
so the thing about parameters is that if
you choose pass one it needs to be one
and this needs to be reflected in the
COBE right if you try pass any more than
one the rest of these parameters will be
ignored
let's have a look at it now so say I
want
pass down a first name into my function
you
and somewhere else in my code I have
recycled this function and written this
okay let's uncomment that
but as soon as I pass on my last name
that part will be ignored
it is the same for if I ask for the last
name and the function but I do not pass
it through I will get undefined
we can also use argument objects
and functions if we declare them outside
of the function we do not need to pass
them through to use them for example I'm
going to write an array called name
now using my function I'm gonna access
the first item of my array so index is
zero like this
you
okay great we are now ready to carry on
with our Tetris walkthrough
in this video we're gonna talk a little
bit about arrow functions and how we're
going to use them in order to draw our
tetriminos onto our grid in this lesson
we're going to be doing more array work
and be introducing something called an
arrow function as well as an inbuilt
JavaScript method called for each arrow
functions were introduced in es6 and
allow us to write shorter function
syntax here is the original way we would
write what was and the evolution to what
we now know at the arrow function if you
have parameters you can pass them
through the brackets like this this is
what we're going to be doing and
evolving the for each method the for
each method calls a provided callback
function once for each element in an
array in ascending order
the callback is invoked for three
arguments the value of the element the
index of the element and the array
object being traversed or in layman
terms we're going to get an array with a
bunch of values and apply logic to each
one here we can see an example of for
each working on an array i have called
item array using this code I'm also
going to pick out each item of that
array so I can apply logic to it you can
see here I've chosen to call it item I
can call it anything I want really
JavaScript all know what I mean it will
know it's an item in my array now using
an error function I do this and add two
to each item in my array so that's the
syntax I don't see an action the
simplest example I can show you of this
happening is when we choose to add
something to each item in our array
let's make an array of names so an array
with strings as indicated by these two
quick marks here and separated by commas
and put them in square brackets now it's
super important to remember what is
inbuilt and what isn't here
names name is our array that we made
above for each is the inbuilt method
that comes with some magic that will
make our javascript do things that was
writing any logic for it name here is
something that we have chosen to call
the items in our array I could call this
whatever I want chair dog my JavaScript
will know I'm
an item in my names array this arrow is
the error function we referred to in our
last video so what we are saying here is
that for each item or name in our names
array we want to print out individually
that name and add this string is the
best to it
okay let's check that out
okay and that has worked great now this
is a super simple example of how to use
for each with an array there are
literally so many different ways to use
this input method
I always think as that is learn with a
working example so let's get going and
use the for each method and our function
to draw a five tetromino shapes onto the
grid let's do this in the next lesson
okay and welcome back this is a
continuation from the last lesson where
we learn about poor each and how we're
going to use it in order to draw the
tetriminos on to our grid game the first
thing we're going to do is get out our
Google sheets again and draw out every
single rotation of each shape note the
otra Mina will say the same during each
rotation and the Zed touch arena and El
techo me know we'll only have two
versions of itself once we are happy
with each of the shapes for rotations
it's time to draw them using our Witt
constant remember we set that as ten in
our JavaScript file let's get going and
start with our l tetra me know we will
set as const as the shape and it's for
rotations will not change you will make
the El techo Mina an array with four
arrays inside it each of the four arrays
is one of its rotations if you see here
what I'm doing is using my drawing to
draw the shape onto the grid as if I was
only allowed to use the grid indexes so
drawing in the index with number one on
our grid shape and index with the number
ten plus one on our grid shape ten being
the width and index number twenty-one
and the index number two it will give us
this shape right here
okay now let's draw the other three
rotations we can do the ball starting
from index zero
no need to draw them in their locations
on my drawing let's do that now
you
once we have done that we need to do the
other four shapes in the same way now
because I have done this before I'm
simply gonna copy this into my project
from my github account you are welcome
to go and grab the tetromino arrays as
well but I would stress that I do advise
against it and only suggest it if you
are stuck and getting some strange
shapes or error messages by trying to
make all the shapes yourself you will
get a better understanding of what we
are doing here and what we are trying to
achieve
it would also defeat the purpose of the
tutorial if you're trying to understand
JavaScript a little bit better I mean
this is the perfect arrays exercise okay
once we have our four shapes let's put
them in an array of their own
let's put this as a Const and call it
the tetriminos
you
okay great we now have our tetriminos
but we can't see them that's because we
need to add some styling to them to see
them first let's decide that we're going
to make them all one color for now just
to make it easier we can change this
later so let's flip over to our style
sheet and add the following
you
okay now let's decide where we want to
start to drug our tetriminos on the
squares grid let's say the first square
of our chosen tetrominos first rotation
array is going to start at the square
with index 4 so let current position
equal 4 now let's pick a tetromino and
its first rotation so let's go to our
the tetriminos array of arrays by
putting a 0 in square brackets like this
we are saying we want to access the
first item on our array let's look at
this slowly
okay so first let's console.log the
tetriminos our array of arrays you can
see that here we have an array of 5
things or as induced 0 to 4 these are
our 5 tetromino shapes if you click on
the first one so index 0 you will see
inside it has its own 4 things in it
these are the faster tribunal shape
rotations we wrote earlier let's click
on the first one so again index 0 this
should look familiar it is the first
rotation in our alpha 2 meter let's go
ahead and now console.log the tetrominos
0 and again in brackets 0
and amazing it's the same we now assign
this variable to current just so we are
all clear I have picked the L tetrominos
first rotation this is now my current
shape okay
now let's draw this using for each to
see if that's true let's write a
function called draw and in that
function let's get on a current array or
what we have assigned is current above
now for each item in that array we want
to add a classic tetromino which would
color that item which is technically a
div inside the element with a class name
of grid
you
so this is how footage works it applies
logic to each item of an array we use
the arrow function here as we saw above
to add the code inside the parenthesis
to each index of the current array just
like we passed the 0 into the array
above to access the first item we are
passing on a number to the square 0 to
correct blue we access the CSS style
sheet by using clusters add two other
style of tetriminos to the squares in
the tetriminos it is in in this occasion
and we are passing through a for this is
because we set the current position as
four plus each index and the currently
chosen tetromino array okay so now let's
invoke this draw function like this
now save your file and quickly go back
to a CSS file to get rid of the red
background we gave all our divs at the
beginning we no longer need this hit
save again
and let's refresh our browser
and great there we go you can now see a
blue tetromino shape it is the elta
Jimena and its first rotation okay now
let's go back to our javascript and
select one of the tetrominos randomly
today's we're gonna be using three more
in book JavaScript methods math.random
which will give us a random number from
our array length length which is an
inbuilt method that will tell us exactly
how long our array is and math.floor
which will round down to the nearest
integer so let's add a variable that
we're going to call random to randomly
select a tetromino from our tetriminos
array we use an inbuilt javascript
method called math.random and multiply
it by the length of our tetriminos array
length being in Beart as well we then
pass this through another input method
called math.floor this will round down
the number to its nearest full integer
okay so let's see if that has worked we
should get a new number each time you
refresh the page
refresh again and great now we have that
let's go back to our current variable
and replace the first zero with random
now what is happening here is that
instead of passing through 0 and
accessing the first item of our H time
we are passing through a number from 0
to 4 randomly this will give back the
first second third fourth or fifth
tetromino in order to Trevino's array
once we have one of these five shapes we
want to access again but always picking
is first rotation let's set this as let
current rotation equals zero
now if he passes through we will always
start at the first rotation of any
random tetromino chosen I'm just going
to change this here to more accurately
reflect what is happening now just to be
as transparent as possible let's invoke
the draw function here to by getting rid
of this code okay now the last thing we
want to do is write a function to unroll
the randomly chosen tetromino and its
current rotation we do the same as we
did to draw it so once again we name the
function on draw we use a for each so
for each item or index in our current
shaped array we look at each of their
current positions add the index of the
shape and pass it through our squares
array now the only difference here is
apart from adding the class we are
removing the class tetromino from its
current location in the grid so it will
visibly disappear from our grid
okay great we now officially have all
our tetriminos and can draw each one on
our grid please do if you're not quite
sure pause here and just have a go at
messing around when the numbers replace
the current position so on just to see
exactly what's happening refresh the
browser loads to see if you'll get in a
random tetromino if not go over this
lesson again I will provide the code
below as well so don't worry if you feel
stuck in the next lesson we're going to
be focusing on moving the tetriminos
around our grid
hey and welcome back in this lesson
we're gonna learn a little bit about
timer IDs and an inbuilt method called
set interval set interval allows us to
invoke a function that we passed through
it after X amount of time in this
example the time is 1000 milliseconds or
in other words one second
we are going to be using set interval
for this project because we want our
tetromino shape to oughta move down the
grid every second just like in the real
game
as mentioned in the example we do this
they pass it through a function that we
will call move down into the set
interval as well as the milliseconds we
want to invoke this function at
we are going to assign this two-timer ID
this is so we can stop the setinterval
in the future
you
now let's write the moves on function
using the functions of an draw and draw
we wrote in our previous lessons so we
want to under the shape from its current
position and add a whole width to the
current position and draw again in its
new position let's check if that has
worked
okay great we can see that the shape is
now also moving down our screen sadly
it's not stopping and going through the
bottom of our grid this is something
that we need to solve we are going to do
this simply by clicking back to our HTML
and adding ten more divs to the bottom
of our two hundred divs this time with a
class name of taken as these do not have
a style in our style sheet they will not
show up visibly we just know that they
have that class if I inspect the page
you will see them there
you
next we need to write a freeze function
in this function we want to write an if
statement an if statement looks like
this we passed through a condition and
brackets before an if whatever the
condition between these brackets is has
to give us a boolean response so a true
or a false if the condition is true we
carry out the next steps of whatever is
in between these two parentheses so here
we have an example if the temperature is
about 20 degrees so this statement is
true you return it is hot now we can
also write an if else statement an
if-else statement is the same as an if
statement however if the condition is
our false we can also return a response
so in this example here if the
temperature is not over 20 degrees we
return it is cold now we can also keep
adding and adding with this else if and
go on forever just like in this example
here so here if the temperature is not
above 20 degrees so false we bypass this
if statement and check the else F if the
temperature is deeply equal to indicated
by these three equal signs that is
deeply equal deeply equal to 18 then we
return at it is warm and of course if it
is not then this statement is also false
and we return a it is called so let's go
back to what we want to happen in our if
statement if some some another inbuilt
JavaScript method similar to how for
each works however instead of applying
logic to each item in our array like for
each with some we are checking that the
logic we write in the brackets is true
for some of the items in our array so
basically if we ever get one true back
we are good to go so if some of the
squares that make up the current
tetromino if their index plus a whole
width so essentially we are checking the
next space down from each square
contains a square with a class name of
taken so if this statement is
true for at least one item in our
current item you know array we turn each
of the tetromino squares into a square
that contains the class of taken
you
got it we then also in we do select a
new tetriminos if your car tetromino
this will be familiar let's get a random
tetromino number
you
we then passes through a tremendous
array and it's fast rotation we then set
this as our current
tetromino then we put it at the current
position so for and finally we draw this
new randomly selected such amino okay
that is it that is our freeze function
let's add this freeze function into our
move down function so that it gets
invoked to check every second oops I
missed the capital M of math here that
is really important please don't forget
to add this here okay great now let's
flip over to our browser and see if that
has worked
you
amazing let's move on to the next lesson
okay so we now have an array of squares
great and we have wrap these squares
over each other to appear like a grid
amazing however in reality how does our
computer know when we are at the very
left hand side of our grid what stops a
touch from you know from going from this
position to this position when we were
being right technically we are in an
array so this would be the next logical
step we need to write a set of rules to
let our JavaScript know when any of our
squares that make up our tetromino are
in a certain indexed square we are going
to do this using good old-fashioned
maths as we can see here our grid has a
width of 10 made up of an array of
squares with indexes 0 to 199 I want to
make sure that if the tetromino is in
the square with index 10 I don't want it
to move left anymore I want to stop it
as otherwise it will appear in the
square with index number 11 so I need to
write a rule that will stop our squares
if they are in the square with index 10
20 30 and so on let's get started by
defining what is a move left function
what we're going to be doing is visually
moving the tetrameter left by drawing it
and undrawn it in the squares we start
off by removing any trace of the shape
in its current location before we start
so that we have a clean slate next we
define what is the left edge and if the
shape is in it this is where our math
comes in for this we use the inbuilt
method called sum again as a recap sum
is a method that looks at each item in
the array and checks if a statement is
true for at least one of the items if it
is the whole statement is therefore true
so once again let's use current as a
reminder current is our current randomly
selected tetromino and its current
rotation
we are checking that some of the current
tetriminos item indexes if divided by
the width leave exactly no remainder
so again if one of the tetromino squares
is in a square let's say that has an
index of 10 we also know that 10 divided
by the width so 10 gives us exactly 0 as
a remainder this means our statement is
true and the shape is at the left hand
side of our grid this is also true for
index 20 30 40 and so on let's use this
information and only allow our shape to
move left or minus one from its current
position in the array if the shape is
not at the left edge indicated by this
exclamation or bang here we also want
our tetromino to stop if there is
another touch romina already there that
has been frozen for this we are gonna
have to have a taken class we are not
gonna star this class we just want to
assign it to the spaces that have been
taken and you can't go into we will use
an if statement for this what we want to
write is if some of the squares in on
touch communicate suddenly go into a
space that contains a class I've taken
while traveling left you want to push it
back one space so it appears not to have
moved
we want to do this for every index in
our tetromino shape so use an arrow
function to do that like this and pass
through the current position and add
every index as it gets passed through
then we add one to the current position
so that moves back to its original space
in the Euro and finally we draw the
tetromino
okay so that was a lot to take in so
before we start writing the move right
to move down and move up function let's
why that's all up to see if it works
fast before we move on
Keiko's are pretty cool every single key
on your keyboard has an assigned code to
it that we can access through our
JavaScript we are going to use this to
make our tetromino move left
if you press key code 37 right if you
press key code 39 and make some
JavaScript magic happen if you press the
button down and so on you can
technically make your such a minami of
left if you press just about any key on
your keyboard that you choose there is
actually a pretty cool site called key
code info that will give you the key
code as soon as you press it when you're
on the site we will also be looking at
passing through events into functions so
that we can use them so let's get
started by assigning key codes to
functions let's write a function called
control and add a document event
listener to listen for any time we press
a key on our keyboard anytime you press
a key on our keyboard we're going to
listen out for which one was clicked and
invert with the control function we are
also going to pass through an e here for
event now with if-statements we're going
to decide what happens when you press a
key if we press the key that deeply
equals key code 37 we want our tetromino
to invoke this function new left let's
see if this works as we wrote the
function in the previous lesson now I'll
give you the coolest part about
JavaScript is making stuff happen in
your browser well you'll be glad to know
this is exactly what the event listener
does the event target method at event
listener sets up a function that we
called whenever the specified event is
delivered to the target common targets
are elements document and window in
laymen terms if you attach an event
listener to something like a div and
click it in your browser cool stuff will
happen you just have to attach it to the
element you have chosen like this you
can see here that we are passing through
two things the type of event so in this
case key up and a function in this case
is the function control we are just
written you can also do remove event
listener to deactivate any listening
happening there are literally so many
events you can use here are just a few
of the
my head so once again the eventlistener
here listens out any time you press a
key on our keyboard using the key up
event if a key is pressed we invoke the
control function we have just written we
attach this event listener to our whole
HTML document okay let's refresh our
browser
and great it works the tetromino is even
stopping when we hit the left-hand side
which is great now let's figure out what
we're going to do for the rest of the
key codes I have commented out the other
functions for now as we have not written
them yet but just so you know what we
need to do so if I press up
I want the shape to rotate if I press
key code 39 and want the shape to go
right and if I press down
I want the shape to go down put pasta
this is something you already have so we
can pass it through here again
you
let's do the move right function based
on the same logic as the move left and
leave the rotate function for the next
lesson
you
so once again we under the squares that
make up adduction we know from their
current indexes we define what it means
when some of the squares that make up
our current amino are in certain indexes
and call this a constant of is a right
edge what you can see is happening here
is that if an index is divisible by the
web and its remainder deeply equals the
width minus one so in this case 9 or 18
or 27 and so on
this statement is true and we are at the
right edge so if we are not at the right
edge indicated by the bank here we can
freely move each square and the
tetromino plus 1 down the array
then if some of the squares that make up
our tetromino are suddenly in a square
that contains the clothes taken we have
to push them back a space in our array
visually making them appear like they
have new double
you
and finally we redraw the tetromino in
its new position
let's try this out
okay great we can now move left to right
without going off the grid and to the
bottom without our tetriminos going past
the squares with the class of taken
let's move on to our next lesson
in this lesson we're going to be doing
more of a work and also looking a little
bit into the increment operator the
increment operator it's going to help us
access the next item in our tetrominos
array we are going to be doing this as
we need to access all four of each of
our tetromino rotations on the click of
a key code we're going to be doing this
using the double plus so plus plus which
works in a way that simply means we are
adding plus one to the defined value
before it it is called an increment
operator in this example you can see how
it works if Y is five and we use the
increment operator on it the Y will now
have a value of six and you guessed it
there's also a decrement operator using
the double - will make the value of our
Y change from five to four now let's use
this in our code we're going to write a
function to rotate the tetromino this is
actually us just skipping to the next
rotation in the current rotation array
as always let's start by on drawing the
shape
next we use the increment operator to
move down to the next item in our array
so the layout of our next rotation we
drew up for the concert Romina
you
using an if statement we say that if the
current rotation index is equal to the
amount of rotations in our current
tetromino shape so for we want to go
back to the first item in our array so
in other words the first rotation they
are again
you
if the statement is false we simply want
to pass through that new current
rotation number into our contact Romina
like this
you
and then we draw it
okay now let's not forget to uncomment
this out here we need to do this so that
when we press the up key the shape will
rotate now let's refresh our page and
see how that works
you
okay great we are now ready to move on
in this lesson we're going to be
covering everything we have learnt
before to essentially build a mini-grid
to the right of our grid right now we
will be doing this so that we can
display the upcoming shapes for our user
this is a great lesson as it can also be
considered a mini recap of all the work
we have done so far we will be going
over how to create a grid pick out
elements to style in our style sheet
pick out elements add functionality to
and how to work with arrays in order to
pick our next shape okay so let's get
started
the first thing I'm going to do is go
over to our HTML and do the following we
are going to add a four by four grid
word game so how do we do this
the same way as we did it before we add
16 divs here and put them in a div you
will choose to call our mini grids
you
now let's flip over to our stylesheet
and similarly to the other grid make our
mini grid 80 by 80 pixels I'm gonna use
flexbox
again and then wrap them over themselves
like this
you
okay great and there we have our mini
grid now I want it to display to the
right of my main grid however to do this
I'm simply going to put two grids and
the two goons only into a div of its own
that I'm going to choose the core
container
you
now back in our stylesheet I'm going to
use flexbox again to make these two
items display:inline
you
I am also going to do one thing to make
it look a little better and that is at a
margin left of 50 pixels
okay great now we can see that there are
two separate grades next to one another
now let's move on to our JavaScript code
so the first thing I want to do is pick
up each div and our mini grid and call
it display squares instead of squares
once again we do this using query
selector all as we want all the divs
inside the div with a class named mini
grid
you
note we are not using away from this
time just to show you a slightly
different approach the next thing we
need to do is tell our JavaScript how
big the width of our mini grid is let's
use display width instead of width for
naming this constant we are also going
to need to set our index at zero let's
call this our display index so our
JavaScript knows we want to talk to the
mini grid only now we need another array
we need an array of our fighter Tommy
knows as they're fast rotations for our
mini grid to show we do not need all the
rotations as we just need to display our
tetromino here
as you can see I am simply rewriting the
Altima nose fast rotation here
same for the Zed T touch me know and so
on
okay now let's get to writing a function
that will display a shape
using the display squares I have
collected so all the DES in our mini
grid I am using for each to get each
item or as I'm gonna call it square and
remove any trace of a tetromino class
from it so that's for the whole mini
grid I'm removing across - shereena from
the whole mini grid
you
next I'm going into the next latet
Ramirez array and using next random so
let's define next random as a value I'm
going to start with the value of 0 so
next round and be 0 let's actually move
this up to the very top of our file we
are doing this as we also need to use it
and the freeze function
you
so right before we choose a random
tetromino for our main grid we are
adding one more step what is happening
here the value next random is being
passed on to the random value so we
choose a next randomly selected
tetromino assign this value to those
random this means we now have a value
okay let's get back to writing or
display shape function
you
for each square that makes up are now
randomly selected up next satrom you
know we want to add a class of tetromino
to it
we then when a pass it through our
display squares hopefully this approach
is now familiar to you
you
let's see if that has now worked save
your file flip over to the browser hit
refresh
you
and great that has now worked now what
would be really great is if we can get
this shape to display as soon as our
game starts for this we're gonna start
to hook up the start and pause button
this was quite a tough section so I
would recommend going slowly on this
section and trying a console log each
step as you code just to make sure you
understand what is happening under the
hood feel free to go over the section
once more if you need to
this lesson is going to be all about
setting intervals and clearing intervals
this is an extension of what we touched
on previously when we taught our
JavaScript that we want the move done
function to invoke every thousand
milliseconds we are now essentially
going to move that function into an
event listener that has attached to our
button that we have an idea of start
button for this means that every time we
press the start button we are going to
invoke the function move down with its
set interval we are also going to go a
step further to see how timer ids work
by adding a pause functionality the
first thing we're going to do is grab
our button we get an ID or start button
- that we called start button above and
attach it to an event listener
ah it's saying not to find let's see why
not okay use the capital here I'm gonna
change this I'm also going to change
this for the school display
okay let's carry on as you can see
everything's really case sensitive and
spelling is really important when coding
I'm also gonna let our timer ID be null
by leaving it blank like this okay so if
the button is clicked and we have at our
MIDI value so the value is not null we
want to pause the game we do this by
passing timer ID through clear interval
like this and setting the value of our
timer ID to null else when the start
button is pressed we draw the tetromino
in what is the default current position
so for put the timer ID on a set
interval of invoking they moved down
function every 1000 milliseconds select
the next random shape you want to
display in our mini grid and evoke the
display shape function we wrote that
will display the randomly selects term
you know we just determined
you
okay great we now need to uninvite them
you don't function that is on a timer
that we wrote previously from our code
so get rid of it unless it's in the
start button eventlistener
you
so what is happening here is that
because we have this line of code the
set interval that starts us at from you
know moving down and vocht on the load
of the browser we want it to be invoked
only if we press the start button
so let's comment this out here and let's
refresh our browser and per fax let's
carry on
you
in this video we're gonna take a break
to look into what exactly splice is and
us using a splice on an array controller
changes content we can remove items from
the array or remove them and replace
them with totally new ones it is
important to note that it will change
the original array once this particular
JavaScript method is used in other words
we are mutating the array so to recap
splice can remove an item or items from
any position in an array splice can also
remove an item or items from any
position in an array and replace them
with new ones let's have a look at how
this works by flipping over to our code
ok let's get an array we can work with
I'm going to call it planets so we now
have an array of four planets now what
if I want to remove Pluto from my array
as I'm not sure of its planet in our
winni days I would use a splice to do
this typing my planets array I would
attach splice to it like this next I
will pass through the index of the item
in my array I want to remove as I only
want to remove that one item I'm gonna
pass in a 1 so 2 1 ok great let's
console.log planet slice 2 1 in brackets
you will see that we should get Pluto
if you console.log planets you will see
that our original planets array now only
contains 3 planets without Pluto ok now
what if I have changed my mind I want to
Riyadh Pluto but also add Uranus we can
use splice to do this let's say I want
to put in the first index of myarray but
not remove anything just put Pluto back
as well as add Uranus I would do so like
this we pass through a 1 for the first
index and a 0 as we don't want to remove
anything and then the two strains we
want to add at index 1 let's have a look
at what this gives us and perfect as you
can probably tell by now
the first two parameters are the start
index and the delete count respectively
leaving the delete count zero will not
remove anything from the array you might
also notice that we get a return of
removed items or item every time we use
splice I have just one more example to
show you before we move on to
implementing this in our Tetris project
so say I want to remove every single
item from my array but Amar's that's
right and I believe that Mars is the
only planet we can do this by simply
passing through the index number into
slice passing this through returns all
of our the planets and if we console.log
planets we will now see it only consists
of Mars ok great now that we have
covered splice let's move on into
implementing it into Tetris
in this section we're gonna be focusing
on what happens when the user managed to
fill a whole row with tetromino squares
we need to do a few things here we need
to remove the roof from our grid or
array add an increased score to our
score tally display the score on our
browser and add a new fresh row to a
grid or array so the grid doesn't appear
to shrink in size for this we're gonna
be focusing on splice concat and
appendchild as we now know the splice
method adds and removes items to and
from arrays and returns removed items
let's move on to concat concat allows us
to merge two arrays together let's use
the same tetriminos array now let's say
we want to add another array to it we do
so using concat here is my second array
and I'm gonna call it shapes by using
the syntax and passing through these
shapes Rea like this we get the two
arrays joined together and finally
append child append child is an inbuilt
JavaScript method that allows us to
append elements to an existing element
for example a grid let's have a look at
how this works in an example first let's
recreate a grid so make a div with a
class of grids now we're going to be
appending divs into this div with a
class of grid so let's add some styling
so we can actually see them
now let's get the div with a class of
grid using our query selector and call
it grid for JavaScript now using Create
element so that's another inbuilt method
let's create a div and our JavaScript
now let's put this create a div into a
grid using a pen child like this and
tada we have now put a little red square
into a div for the class of grid now
let's use these three input methods in
our project let's get the lesson started
by creating our add school function
where we want all the steps outline to
happen the first thing we're gonna do is
write a for loop this loop will loop
over entire grid and all its squares
every 10 squares so with my whip the for
loop syntax in George grip looks a
little bit like this in this example
what we are doing here is three things
setting a variable before the loop
starts so far equals zero defining the
condition for the loop to run so I must
be less than 5 and incrementing the
value by one using the increment
operator we move on to the next item in
our array to loop over so what would
this look like let's have a look with an
example an array that I have called
shapes now if we use the for loop to
loop over the length of the array and
loop over each item one by one what will
we get
every console.log shapes you will get a
list of the shapes printed out in our
console.log
okay now let's use this in a project
we nexif i and what we want our road to
be this will be the i+ every square that
makes up a row now we use an inbuilt
method called every to check if every
square and are defined row contains a
div with a class of taken if it does and
the statement is true we do a few things
we add 10 to the score we display the to
our user using the score display and an
inbuilt method called inner HTML and for
each item the row we remove the class of
taken
and we take out this row using splice
like this I have a sinus taken out row
to a Const called
squares removed let's console.log this
to see what is happening
okay great
you can see here what our row is and
what is made up of now let's riad these
squares to our squares array so that the
grid
doesn't appear smaller so what we're
going to do is we're going to append
these new squares to our grid
let's go back to our browser hit refresh
and great you will see here that our row
has cut itself out and appended itself
to the beginning of our array okay let's
remove the cross tetromino so the blue
so that it looks like it should
amazing we are now down to the final
stage of our game which is defining what
a game over is
we are now nearly at the end of our
tetris course by now you would have
covered all the following inbuilt
JavaScript methods and use them in our
project this is pretty impressive we
only have one more thing let's do and
that is define what is our game over now
as you know tetris finishes when you
stack up or you'll touch aminos so that
they don't fit in the grid anymore this
makes our writing of the gaming of a
definition super simple all we have to
do is tell our JavaScript that if there
is a taken shape present in the original
default position or index for we call it
a game over okay let's write our game
over function we're going to write a
game of a function in it we are gonna
have an if statement that says if some
of our current tetromino shape that is
in play if some of its items or index is
at the current tetriminos composition
contain the class of taken we call our
game over
we then display this in our school
display we then also clear the games
timer IDs so that the autumn you down
function stops
you
and there we have it a fully functioning
game of tetris now I would love you to
take this game make your own share with
me on YouTube my channel is Anna Kubo or
on Twitter and your underscore Kubo I
would love to see what you're made and
how you've taken this and made your own
and taking it to the next level the
options for you to do this are adding
levels adding a line count may be having
some music to the game or just styling
your game to the max I do have one final
lesson for you that I think might be
quite interesting that is to do with
styling of the tetromino colors if you
want to learn how to do this and also
wanna learn how to tidy up your code for
best practice please do watch my final
video for this series
hi and welcome to the last video in my
JavaScript games tutorial if you want to
learn how to assign colors each from you
know and also wanna learn how to tidy up
your code for best practice definitely
watch this last video in the series once
again I hope you have enjoyed this
series and if you do have any questions
please do not hesitate to contact me on
my socials below ok so the last thing we
want to do is assign colors to each of
our tetriminos you will do this in our
JavaScript file first we want to make a
Const called colors in it I'm gonna put
the colors I want my tetriminos to be in
in the same order as they appear in my
tetriminos array this means my alt
search I mean I wanna be orange my Zed
touch me know will not be red and so on
you
now that we have that we need to find
each time we add and remove the class
list of tetromino in our code so we can
add this color on top of it so after
that line of code has been written the
first instance I can see this in is in
the draw function let's use style and
background color to add styling in our
JavaScript file we also pass through
whatever value is currently random into
our colors array this means that if the
random tetromino is currently the l
tetromino the color we will get back
will be orange each time as we are
passing through zero to remove the color
as we need to do for undraw we just
leave an empty string like this
you
we also need to do this for the
mini-grid where it displays the next
shape let's do the same passing through
next random instead of random
you
finally the only place remove the color
is here in the ad score function
you
let's see if that has worked and wait
now just a quick cleanup you can see
here getting rid of any additional lines
commented out codes and changing this as
it should be a conce not alert
and there we have it thank you so much
for watching my video